elle n'est pas la seule mais c'est la
cheminée du creusot l'emblématique érigé
en 1870 classé à l'inventaire des
monuments historiques
ce prestige n'a pas empêché les outrages
du temps sa partie supérieure
s'abîmaient il fallait soit la réduire
soit la battre alors en juin 2016 ce
monument a été amputé de 8 m 74 par une
entreprise spécialisée dans les travaux
d'altitude qui était important aussi
c'était de pouvoir conserver les rives
et puisqu'en fait cette cheminée avait
de la valeur parce que elle était en
taule rift quelques mois plus tard
pourquoi retrouve-t-on des morceaux de
cette cheminée dans la petite cour d'une
maison creusotine ornée de peintures
représentant le paysage industriel de la
ville
voici l'histoire racontée par ses deux
protagonistes les tôles devait partir à
la série et je me suis dit que ça serait
vraiment dommage donc j'ai proposé à
l'entreprise qui découpe et la cheminée
de racheter de racheter en fait le stock
pour pouvoir le valoriser savait que
christian faisait régulièrement des
peintures dans le creusot notamment
j'avais vu des petites peintures de lui
de la grande cheminée et je lui ai dit
écoute christian ça serait peut-être
bien que tu payes la cheminée sur des
sur des morceaux en trimestre de cette
cheminée
sa proposition
c'est vrai qu'elle était un peu
surprenante et puis il puis j'étais pas
très j'étais pas très chaud bon ça s'est
arrangé par la suite je suis allé voir
sur les lieux
la cheminée en question et je me suis
surtout penché sur le l'aspect graphique
au niveau de cet acier
comment ils étaient granuleux irrégulier
rouillé voilà comment christian segaud a
trouvé ce matériau pour cet homme qui
peint sa ville depuis des décennies ce
voyageur d'ici comme ils se nomment il
s'agissait d' ajouter sa petite touche
discrète à ces plaques d'acier il
fallait que l'on sorte un objet brut
ordinaire simple et puis avec une touche
de poésie
il faut toujours remettre une touche de
poésie sur les choses certaines plaques
ont déjà été donnés ou vendus
certaines sont encore à vendre toutes
sont accompagnées d'un certificat
d'authenticité
elles proviennent bien de cette
magnifique cheminée
[Musique]